oh hello welcome to this video this was
a bit strange i had sound turn off and
totally screwed up my configuration so
it took me a while Jim really has
started the recording so we a
transposition into the Sicilian can but
why not playing Billy Corgan from the
Netherlands hear the young Mickey Liang
okay and I don't don't know him
personally mm-hmm but seems to be a fan
of the smashing pumpkins let's see if
I've yeah that's somewhat added this
this sir became fashionable recently
think Bishop g5 is the right move as
weird as it looks take sandy five I hope
I'm not confusing things here but I
really think this is right okay if I go
to h4 hmm yeah there's probably really
g5g I'm so I'm taking and now night f5
there's d5 yeah I think this is how they
played this line yeah I took me took me
some time to remember Oh interesting
he's not playing d5 so i get i get to
play night 25-year i don't i don't
really think that this should be any
good for black is this strange
look strange to me but maybe I'm too
conservative a player to to appreciate
what's going on here the night here back
to e3 on is there any any direct attempt
before it's also very interesting but
before I will probably go back to a fade
otherwise I come to this exon we are
still F aid you half the night is
reenter that's not so bad but before
it's not a useless movie and so I'll do
that okay maybe I'm just taking ages to
play you all knowing a well-known book
line that's certainly possible ok trying
to use the v6 square and now we cannot
play Bishop g7
k Knight b6 or the capture maybe the
captions night here then Bishop c4 to d5
yeah this should be a good structure
really so he wants to capture with the
pawn he ever take a eye takes with the
pawn but I I wanted to play this in any
case
yeah now it needs to catch up with the
Queen as I'm taking these six with a
check in case of the pawn recapture and
after Queen takes I can get in 93 to d5
and this is really a nice position the
only problem is that building up this
very nice position took me lots of time
simply figuring out the initial move the
position itself is is very very nice
okay taking what the queen is also
interesting but I like to get the the
rooks traded of course check simplifying
a bit because of the low time and if I
get all heavy pieces of I'm simply
winning the game because of the bad
structure so we cannot play Queen f7 or
something or hear a fear after this move
would trade queens I'm just winning what
cannot be serious this is just a win on
the queenside yeah sorry if I'm if I'm
so so Frank here but that's absolutely
not playable he does not have anything
on the kingside the 90s was protecting
e7f 6 he cannot enter here and I'm just
winning here with King king / be five at
the end and it's it's a very simple win
yeah I will he can take then I will
approach with the king or just open the
queenside it's also also winner this is
just check getting a day six born so the
Queen trade is really a completely
completely unplayable it was very tricky
in any case but this some I should have
of course I must take with the other
poem ah ok hmm of course with that just
take with the earth point and then it's
it's gone I hope this is winning anyway
but that it wasn't necessary of course
check want to bring go over to g7 check
check check and how this should be a
meeting attack yeah it does what lager
that was really lucky well still
reflecting now how strange this decision
was to to enter the endgame time I was
serving check simply not paying
attention check check I'm going to
trying to figure out the right way to do
this made neck smooth black resigns yeah
well this was very very stupid of course
I just take with the f porn and there is
no no nothing to calculate even as the
apron just promotes but the absolute
weirdest thing is the Queen trade and in
two seconds I mean this is totally lost
I mean not it's not even close to to be
to be tenable and the computer doesn't
understand the position that's funny it
only gives white 0.4 this is this is
funny really it is just it just flat-out
winning maybe it is it is too deep to
see that the green side is collapsing at
the end you must retreat the Queen
unlike here and then continue continue
from that so I'm an excellent position
with the dominating knight on d5 but but
still it's not as as hopeless as the
Queen trade this is really
straightforward there's nothing that
like a new g5 is not helping but you
will lose the game on the queenside
anyway in the very long run yeah if you
take you will open up here and at the
end you and you you win by a check by
zoosk one with Knight b6 King here and
so on at the end you will pick up all
the points its am relatively
straightforward yeah the whole opening
was was strange of course this is a very
interesting line intact
five approach this has become my
fashionable recently Bishop g5 i think
is is the the way to go yeah of course
after this there is e5 and this is very
dangerous for black this is the one that
this is what I know I am NOT not knowing
at much more something like this year
the problem should be that the e-file is
opening up you look at this giggles
castling rides and white yeah white is
some is a pawn down but ok what point is
this is this kind of weird double porn
the be this will be a very strong attack
so this was was played and now I think
they play d5 yeah FC I've seen this
night see 3d 495 and then back which
looks weird because of the development
but yeah there are some issues this is
of course a threat so white needs to
attend to that and he does not have them
a clearly good move to do it to do it
well that's all I know not not more but
ok this was played but I really don't
think that this should be any good you
had the computer approves that's
reassuring playing all the column was
funny right but it took me some time
this and now the computer is giving c3
and then f4 is even better yeah this
looked logical like a five coming and f4
again by the compound maybe need to be
more forceful I was I was thinking about
that but only somewhat later here I was
thinking maybe I can do something with
the development but I was just going for
them for the good structure here the
captcha would take with the pawn and our
in fact this is also great yeah that's
also a great position I wanted to avoid
that and want to want to take the piece
then it was nice that here
he was forced to take with the Queen and
then we get this very one sided
structure with the eternal nightie on d5
and it was just very very one-sided
after the capture Queen takes is also
very interesting because the Queen only
four is also pretty much yeah
unassailable it cannot really play this
air because of the knight on d5 it's
also good but I wanted to get heavy
pieces off and he just traded like check
there is nothing going on which which I
found remarkable the ante as mentioned
this is a winning endgame the computer
in here stockfish and the engineer does
not recognize this quite funny but it
takes a while yeah the computer is
coming pretty deep here but to
appreciate that let's say with a king on
c6 at the end with the queenside
exchange that this is a win this is
really deep I mean the computer must
calculate really deeply so it starts
seeing this in like two or three seconds
but this is really am pin really am a
very very bad end game okay thanks for
watching